[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal bettina
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend wenn die angaben
aus russland stimmen dann hat die
ukraine heute erstmals einen luftangriff
auf russischem staatsgebiet ausgeführt
zwei ukrainische militärhubschrauber
sollen ein öllager 40 kilometer hinter
der grenze beschossen haben sagt der
gouverneur des gebiets das ukrainische
verteidigungsministerium sagt die
angaben seien nicht korrekt die
verteidiger melden heute erfolge der
krieg läuft aber mit unverminderter
härte weiter und das rote kreuz sagt um
den horror für die menschen in der
hafenstadt mario pohl zu beschreiben
gehen uns die worte aus christian kirsch
berichtet
überschreitet der krieg die grenzen der
ukraine fünf wochen nach ausbruch der
kämpfe diese bilder ein brennendes
öllager nahe der stadt belgorod nördlich
archiv auf russisches staatsgebiet nach
russischen angaben sollen zwei
ukrainische hubschrauber die anlage in
brand geschossen haben die ukraine
widerspricht die vorwürfe russlands
entsprechen nicht der wahrheit im umfeld
der hauptstadt kiew ziehen sich die
russischen truppen weiter zurück den
vorrückenden ukrainern bietet sich ein
trümmerfeld wirklich ein rückzug
na ja sagt präsident selensky im don was
in mario pohl in der gegend um haghof
sammelten sich truppen für gewaltige
angriffe wir werden uns verteidigen
zwischen den trümmern und zerschossenen
fahrzeugen immer wieder tote 29
siedlungen so der ukrainische
generalstab heute habe man zurückerobert
mario pohl eine trümmerlandschaft
russland verkündete heute eine
feuerpause in der geschundenen stadt
zivilisten sollen mario pohl verlassen
nur wie
wohin fragt sie können wir denn gehen
wir haben angst können sie sich
vorstellen zwischen toten zu leben und
zu gehen das internationale rote kreuz
plante heute versorgungsgüter in die
stadt zu bringen
und einige busse in denen menschen in
sicherheit gebracht werden sollten am
abend hieß es der versuch sei
gescheitert
viele versuchen es weiter auf eigene
faust kinder steht auf dem schild sie
haben es geschafft mit dem eigenen auto
raus aus mario pohl
wir hatten glück sie wurden nicht
beschlossen aber die beiden konvois vor
uns mussten umkehren weil sie unter
feuer gerieten
hier in kiew schützen sie ein denkmal
mit sandsäcken auch mehr als 50
kulturstätten sagt die unesco seien
inzwischen zerstört kirchen museen an
einen wirklichen rückzug der russischen
armee glauben sie hier in der hauptstadt
nicht
ich glaube es ist nur ein versuch putins
sein gesicht zu wahren vor der
russischen bevölkerung denn offenbar ist
sein plan vom blitzkrieg nicht
erfolgreich
hier vorerst verschont angespannte ruhe
atempause mitten im krieg
[Musik]
ganz entscheidend dafür wie es
weitergeht mit dem krieg in der ukraine
und entscheidend dafür wie es weitergeht
zwischen russland und dem rest der welt
ist die rolle die china spielt die
weltwirtschaft ordnet sich gerade neu
und die führung in peking will dabei
eine hauptrolle spielen am liebsten die
hauptrolle und hält sich deshalb erst
mal nach allen seiten offen dem nachbarn
russland hat china gerade eine zitat
freundschaft ohne grenzen zugesagt und
richtung putin bislang kein kritisches
wort verloren umgekehrt will china enger
mit europa zusammenarbeiten um noch ein
zitat den frieden bald zurückkehren zu
lassen das ist die offizielle
chinesische bilanz des eu-china video
gipfels heute welche strategie die
mächtigen in peking genau fahren ist
dabei genauso unklar wie die frage wie
soll sich die eu verhalten aus brüssel
anne gellinek
eu-china-gipfel und die begrüßung sagt
schon viel bloß kein lächeln kein zurück
winken die zeiten sind nicht danach der
chinesische präsident hu jintao hat nur
eine knappe stunde zeit ansonsten müssen
die eu-spitzen mit dem premierminister
vorlieb nehmen die botschaft an beide
ist die gleiche china soll seine
unterstützung für putins krieg in der
ukraine aufgeben der minimalkonsens
klingt so
die eu und china sind sich einig dass
dieser krieg die globale sicherheit und
die weltwirtschaft gefährdet diese
unsicherheit ist weder in china noch in
europas interesse
china spielt ein doppeltes spiel bislang
hat die eu keine beweise dass es
wirklich waffen an russland liefert oder
die westlichen sanktionen unterläuft
aber dass es politisch fest an russland
seite steht wird auch heute wieder klar
die usa haben als täter und anstifter
der ukraine krise die nato dazu gebracht
sich in fünf wellen nach osten zu
erweitern und russland schritt für
schritt an die wand zu drücken
wir haben auch sehr klar gemacht dass
china wenn er schon unsere sanktionen
nicht unterstützt sie wenigstens nicht
stören sollte kein europäischer bürger
würde verstehen wenn china durch seine
haltung diesem russischen krieg
verlängern würde
die europäer versuchen es mit einer art
beschwörung es müsse doch in chinas
interesse sein weltwirtschaft und
lieferketten am laufen zu halten und die
beidseitigen wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu
stärken europa ist chinas größter
handelspartner noch vor den usa so gehen
immerhin 15 prozent aller chinesischen
exporte in länder der eu aber nur 1,5
prozent von chinas waren nach russland
von sanktionen gegen china will in
brüssel bislang niemand reden dafür ist
das china geschäft zu wichtig eine
offene militärische unterstützung
russlands aber wäre eine rote linie für
europa da hat man dann schon der
chinesischen seite auch signalisiert
dass man maßnahmen ergreifen würde diese
würden aber keinesfalls so umfangreich
ausfallen wie gegen russland denn das
ein ganz anderes wirtschafts- verhältnis
die wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen sind
von ganz anderer natur da würde europa
selber große probleme bekommen unterm
strich bleibt das china zumindest
während des gesprächs mit der eu seine
pro russische rhetorik nicht wiederholt
hat eingelenkt aber hatte jean ping
genauso wenig eine gemeinsame
abschlusserklärung war erst gar nicht
geplant es gibt wohl im moment zu wenig
gemeinsamkeiten die es aufzuschreiben
lohnte
partner wettbewerber oder rivale und
irgendwie alles gleichzeitig so scheint
china aus europas sicht gucken wir auf
die sicht aus peking mit unser mann in
peking wohl voller guten abend hat sich
den peking festgelegt was europa für
china sein soll
ich glaube für peking ist europa vor
allem eins ein ganz ganz wichtiger
absatzmarkt von hohen nationalen
interesse man muss ja verstehen dass das
chinesische modell also das angebot der
regierung an seine bevölkerung hier in
china ganz einfach ist es heißt wir
organisieren euch einen wirtschaftlichen
aufstieg und dafür haltet ihr den mund
und folgt der kommunistischen partei und
um diesen wirtschaftlichen aufstieg hier
in peking zu organisieren braucht man
eben europa europa als absatzmarkt ist
wie gesagt sehr wichtig für chinas
stabilität und dann gibt es noch einen
politischen grund europa ist auch eine
begehrte braut im bündnis verhältnis man
weiß ja dass das westliche bündnis mit
amerika zur zeit durch den krieg sehr
starkes zwischen europa amerika und
chinas langfristige politik ist
eigentlich europa von amerika zu
distanzieren shipping will anteile
dieses bündnis treiben dann dann der das
westliche bündnis schwach oder
geschwächt und das ist im sinne von
peking ist er noch anzunehmen dass china
irgendwann wegen des krieges von
russlands seite weicht
also ich glaube dass dieses verhältnis
zwischen putin und präsident sie nun
wirklich kein sehr romantisches
verhältnis ist sondern ein verhältnis
ist das komplett interessengesteuert ist
also wenn der russische präsident in
massive schwierigkeiten gerät im ukraine
konflikt wenn er probleme zu hause
bekommt dann glaube ich auch würde man
ihn hier in peking fallen lassen weil
shipping will nicht mit verlierern auf
der weltbühne stehen aber dann kurz
verstehen es geht eigentlich weniger um
putin als person sondern dafür es geht
darum was putin steht für wasser steht
nämlich für ein system ein
diktatorisches das bereit ist dem westen
und vor allem den fahrten amerikanern
die stirn zu bieten und darin kann
shipping sich wirklich wieder finden
denn genau das will auch hier in der
region machen amerika die stirn bieten
insofern geht es eigentlich bei diesem
ukraine krieg um ein großes duell der
beiden blöcke der bald neun blöcke auf
der einen seite amerika europa und auf
der anderen seite russland und china und
deswegen glaube ich am ende des tages
wird sie chipping immer für diesen blog
scheiben und er wird immer diktator
bleiben interessante analyse auch heute
abend wieder und herzlichen dank dafür
nach peking
nicht nur china hat bislang weder
sanktionen verhängt noch russland sonst
irgendwie verurteilt auch indien fährt
dieselbe linie und damit während es
bereits die beiden bevölkerungsreichsten
länder der welt in china war russlands
außenminister gerade dreimal dürfen sie
raten wo er heute ist richtig in delhi
bei indiens premierminister der den
handel mit russland ausbauen will und
oft günstiges russisches öl schielt da
kann der gast aus moskau liefern normen
odenthal mit mehr
willkommen zu sein oft kann russlands
außenminister lavrov dieses gefühl
derzeit nicht haben heute schon indien
empfängt ihn herzlich so hat sich der
russe das vorgestellt
unsere kollegen aus dem westen versuchen
jedes außenpolitische thema auf die
krise in der ukraine zu reduzieren
unsere position ist ja bekannt wir
verheimlichen nichts und wir wissen zu
schätzen dass indien die gesamtlage mit
allen fakten betrachtet und dabei nicht
parteiisch ist
unser treffen findet heute in einer
schwierigen internationalen lage statt
sie wissen dass indien immer bemüht ist
meinungsverschiedenheiten und streit mit
dialog und diplomatie zu begegnen
klingt unparteiisch aber ist es dass
indien jedenfalls nutzt die gunst der
stunde bietet sich als williger abnehmer
russischer rohstoffe an was andere
verschmähen ist gerade günstig zu haben
und indien kauft mehr denn je
indien ist natürlich an billigem öl und
gas interessiert die preise sind zuletzt
ja stark gestiegen jeder mensch tut das
doch wenn preise steigen jeder
vergleicht an und kauft in dem
supermarkt wo brot oder reis günstig ist
so macht indien das auch dem westen
gefällt das natürlich nicht er übt druck
auf in den aus aber indien kann das
sicher aushalten
das ist keine einzelmeinung in indien
delhis offizielle linie findet breite
unterstützung dass sich enthalten bei
sanktionen der uno das nicht verurteilen
der russischen invasion
in der weltpolitik geht es immer ums
überleben realistisch betrachtet muss
sich ändern um seine interessen kümmern
und da gibt es nichts zu rechtfertigen
indien sollte russland ganz offen
unterstützen
wir können doch nur gewinnen wir können
öl direkt aus russland kaufen zu guten
preisen das sind starke
handelsbeziehungen auch bei
rüstungsgütern
gerade bei rüstungsgütern raketensysteme
kampfjets waffen aller art mehr als die
hälfte des indischen militär geräts soll
aus russischer produktion stammen indien
werde beliefert was immer es bestelle
sattler wolf heute abgewickelt würden
die geschäfte direkt zwischen rupie und
rubel
der grund warum wir auf unseren
nationalen währungen setzen ist die
unzuverlässigkeit des westens wir wollen
nicht von einem zahlungssystem abhängig
sein dass sie jederzeit einstellen
können ein system dessen herren unser
geld im handumdrehen einfach stehlen
können
russland und indien indien und russland
eine seiner letzten reisen vor dem krieg
führte putin zum modi bester dinge der
inder versuchte stets den balance akt
zwischen west und ost wollte er sich
auch mit den usa nicht verscherzen es
wird aber wohl immer schwerer diese
balance zu halten
ja es sind einige waghalsige balance
akte zu beobachten in dieser welt
aktuell auch direkt bei uns vor der tür
in ungarn und in serbien sind am sonntag
wahlen für beide dort amtierenden
spitzenleute war wladimir putin bislang
kein vorbild und einer mit dessen
energielieferungen man die wähler
glücklich machen konnte beide
spitzenleute scheinen wenig grund zu
sehen ihre rolle und die von putin zu
überdenken
während in ungarn die opposition mit
einem zweckbündnis den machtwechsel
erreichen will sitzt serbiens starker
mann fest im sattel ausgerechnet der
krieg in der ukraine könnte dem
autoritär gesonnen putin freund die
wiederwahl sichern wolf christian
ullrich hat mehr dazu
für serbien ist präsident vujic so
unersetzbar wie ein fruchtzwerge sein
wirken und seine botschaften so
überlebenswichtig dass sie in jedem
kühlschrank gehören so suggeriert ist
dieser wahlwerbespot was viele serben
den präsidenten zu gute halten sie haben
arbeit deutsche autozulieferer zum
beispiel lassen inzwischen vermehrt in
serbien produzieren
was das wichtigste für mich ist wir
bauen fabriken fabriken und noch mehr
fabriken
für deutsche elektro autos wollte er
hier in unberührter landschaft in großem
stil lithium abbauen enteignungen und
lasche umweltauflagen sollten dabei
helfen die wut der anwohner führte im
letzten jahr zu heftigen protesten und
gab der opposition so viel rückenwind
das widget das projekt überraschend
stoppte das umweltschutz im wahlkampf
eine rolle spielt ist neu vor allem
kämpft die liberale opposition für
rechtsstaatlichkeit und für serbiens weg
in die eu
wir müssen in die europäische union wir
müssen frieden mit unseren nachbarn
finden und in die europäische familie
denn da gehören sie hin
serbien in der eu dabei kopiert vucic
doch ausgerechnet viktor orban mithilfe
treuer oligarchen nationalismus
schmieren kampagnen und medienkontrolle
drängte er die opposition in die ecke
errichtet ein strammes machtsystem
brüssel und berlin nahmen das bis jetzt
alles lächelt in kauf europa geht es um
einfluss denn seit jahren laviert wut
zwischen der eu und china als investoren
und putins russland als politischen
partner
beide länder verbinden kulturell
religiöse wurzeln bei öl und gas ist
serbien von russland abhängig
putin unterstützt serbische
nationalisten die im nachbarland bosnien
und herzegowina für unruhe sorgen und
kosovo nicht als unabhängig ansehen
unter vujic anhängern viele russland
freunde doch auch die angesichts des
krieges gespalten
ich bin nicht für sanktionen aber ich
unterstütze die territoriale integrität
der ukraine
serbien hat bei den vereinten nationen
putins krieg mit verurteilt deutet sich
eine neupositionierung
anmutig ich kann nicht mehr die
russische karte
ziehen so wie es bis jetzt gemacht hat
muss natürlich auch aufgrund der
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen mit dem
westen und auch der politischen
bedeutung des westens pragmatischer
werden doch coach kennt die rote linie
in seinem land
wir werden niemals der nato beitreten
drahtseilakt zwischen ost und west
sollte er die wahl gewinnen könnte vucic
danach zu antworten gezwungen seien
die folgen des krieges gegen die ukraine
damit beginnt auch du hanna jetzt seine
nachrichtenübersicht bundeskanzler
scholz hat heute mit vertretern der
kommunen über die verteilung von
geflüchteten aus der ukraine beraten und
darüber wer die kosten für sie übernimmt
die bundesregierung sicherte den
kommunalen spitzenverbänden ihre
unterstützung zu diese fordern vom bund
unter anderem die zahlung einer
pauschale für jeden geflüchteten darüber
gab es heute keine einigung bund und
länder wollen in einer arbeitsgruppe ein
finanzierungskonzept erarbeiten das am
kommenden donnerstag geschlossen werden
soll
die bundesanwaltschaft hat anklage gegen
einen ehemaligen reserveoffizier der
bundeswehr erhoben ihm wird vorgeworfen
für den russischen geheimdienst
spioniert zu haben
zwischen 2014 und 2020 habe der mann den
russischen nachrichtendienst mit
informationen versorgt erklärte die
bundesanwaltschaft
dabei soll es unter anderem um die
gaspipeline nord stream zwei gegangen
sein wegen seines zivilen berufs gehörte
der beschuldigte mehreren ausschüssen
der deutschen wirtschaft an die anklage
wurde bereits am 16 märz erhoben
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
vor dem ende zahlreicher chor ohne
beschränkungen in deutschland zu
weiterer vorsicht aufgerufen er rät zu
in innenräumen weiterhin masken zu
tragen
auch wenn laut robert-koch-institut der
höhepunkt der korona welle
wahrscheinlich erreicht ist innerhalb
eines tages wurden 252
1530 neuinfektionen registriert das sind
fast 44.000 weniger als vor einer woche
304 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage ins ident ist ebenfalls gesunken
auf 1500
86,4
die kriegsparteien im jemen haben sich
auf eine waffenruhe von zwei monaten
geeinigt da der vereinigten nationen
soll die feuerpause morgen beginnen in
jemen tobt seit sieben jahren einen
stellvertreterkrieg
der iran unterstützt die schiitischen
houthi-rebellen saudiarabien und andere
golfstaaten die truppen der
jemenitischen regierung die vereinigten
nationen schätzen dass durch den krieg
und den hunger im jemen bereits etwa
380.000 menschen gestorben sind
die bundesregierung will sich nicht
länger an der europäischen anti
piraterie operation atalanta am horn von
afrika beteiligen das bundeswehr mandat
werde nicht verlängert weil die
piraterie vor der küste somalias
erfolgreich reduziert wurde erklärte das
bundesverteidigungsministerium
2008 war die mission ins leben gerufen
worden um die seewege sicherer zu machen
ende april läuft das mandat für den
einsatz aus
auch wenn es auf den ersten blick so
aussieht das hier ist keine große
lieferung von neuen fußbällen für die
fifa zentrale
das sind auch keine mitarbeiter der
züricher stadtreinigung es ist die
aktion eines künstlers mit ernstem
hintergrund er will hinweisen auf die
lage der menschenrechte im
austragungsland der nächsten wm katar wo
amnesty international und human rights
watch heute wieder alarm schlagen
angekommen von alledem ist hinter den
mauern bei den offiziellen des
weltfußballs nicht viel fifa chef gianni
infantino ist gerade in doha der
hauptstadt von katar und er sagt einen
satz den sie bei olympia immer am ende
der spiele sagen sicherheitshalber schon
mal bevor es überhaupt losgeht es wird
die beste wm der geschichte béla réthy
und markus haben er hatte es zumindest
nicht weit von zuhause fifa-boss gianni
infantino lebt inzwischen in doha mehr
als eine deutliche zuwendung an den
umstrittenen 7 glas gebe alle
weltmeisterschaften als die wm vor zwölf
jahren nach katar vergeben wurde
ignorierte man alle vorbehalte bezüglich
der menschenrechte dem arbeitsschutz
oder der diskriminierung von
minderheiten jetzt steht alles bereit
nachdem angeblich 6500 menschen auf den
baustellen gestorben sind
die auslosung der erste sportliche
termin der 22 wm deutschland das
weltranglisten-zwölfte nicht gesetzt
wird vom wm rekordspieler lothar
matthäus in die gruppe mit spanien
gezogen
zuletzt traf man sich bei einer wm 2010
in südafrika
in deutschland verlor das halbfinale mit
0 zu 1 spanien wurde später zum einzigen
mal weltmeister
so lautete diesmal der eigene anspruch
was ist denn die klare zielvorgabe der
titel die haben ja wir haben ja gesagt
dass wir dass wir weltmeister werden
wollen oder dass ich glaube alle spieler
ob das manuel neuer thomas müller sind
sind beides auch die schon ein gewisses
alter haben natürlich natürlich auch
noch mal im finale stehen wollen bei
einer weltmeisterschaft und werden alles
dafür tun auch wenn spanien gute
erinnerungen an die dfb-elf hat das
wunschlos ist es nicht
okay das ist wie ich die beste
mannschaft die man bekommen konnte
deutschland war das stärkste team für
mich aus topf 2 aber wie auch immer alle
mannschaften sind hier weil sie große
mannschaften haben
auch japan regelmäßig dabei der erste
deutsche gegner bei dem turnier bisher
gab es lediglich zwei
freundschaftsspiele gegen einander
zuletzt 2006 in leverkusen da gelang
schweinsteiger nach 0 2 rückstand
immerhin der ausgleich wir haben viele
japaner in der bundesliga ich sehe
dadurch ständig den deutschen fußball
und bin zuversichtlich dass wir gut
aussehen werden
offen ist noch die frage kommt costa
rica oder
neuseeland in die gruppe e das
entscheidet sich im juni in den playoffs
bei seinem ersten turnier als
cheftrainer hat hansi flick eine
schwierige gruppe erwischt abgesehen von
spanien und also die beiden trainer
schon bei der ankunft geahnt hätten dass
es zum duell kommt
drei weitere wm tickets werden noch
vergeben auch die ukrainische fußball
nationalmannschaft hat noch eine chance
sie muss dazu im juni erst gegen
schottland gewinnen und dann noch gegen
wales
und hier bei uns jetzt nochmal hanna und
zwar mit einem rekordwert den die
inflation im euroraum im märz erreicht
hat 7,5 prozent das hat es seit der
einführung des euro noch nicht gegeben
und ist auch deutlich mehr als von
experten erwartet hauptgrund für den
anstieg sind die energiekosten laut euro
statt liegt das plus im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat bei
44,7 prozent aber auch in anderen
bereichen ist das leben deutlich teurer
geworden unter anderem bei den
nahrungsmitteln und hier dürften die
preise auch noch weiter nach oben
klettern
davon geht der handelsverband
deutschland aus von zweistelligen
preissteigerungen ist die rede sina
mainitz an der frankfurter börse und
bereits am montag könnte sich das an den
supermarktkassen ganz konkret bemerkbar
machen genau dann will discounter
marktführer aldi seine preise abermals
anheben erst kürzlich hat eine
preiserhöhung gegeben innerhalb der
vergangenen zwei wochen sind 180
produkte beim einzelhandelsriesen dann
teurer geworden die preise für
lebensmittel erhöhen sich ab kommenden
montag wieder um 20 bis 50 prozent bei
der butter liegt das plus bei 30 prozent
andere händler haben ebenfalls höhere
preise angekündigt laut einer umfrage
des münchner ifo instituts wollen 94
prozent der lebensmittelhändler
demnächst die preise erhöhen und damit
ihre höheren lieferanten preise an die
verbraucher weitergeben der anhaltende
krieg in der ukraine lieferengpässe
exportstopps bei agrarrohstoffen und
immer höhere energiekosten schlagen sich
nun auch auf den lebensmittelbereich
nieder ein blick auf steigende
lebensmittelpreise trafen sich heute die
agrarminister von bund und ländern es
wurde diskutiert ob brachliegende
agrarflächen zeitweise für den
nahrungsmittelanbau freigegeben werden
sollen damit könnte drohende
nahrungsmittel engpässen entgegengewirkt
werden einigen konnte man sich nicht
nächsten freitag soll nun der bundesrat
final darüber entscheiden der dax
schließt am ende der woche im plus mit
einem hand von 14.400 46 punkten leicht
gestärkt geht er damit zwar in den april
doch das minus beim dax im ersten
quartal dieses jahres die dieses jahres
jahr liegt bei fast 10 prozent danke sie
nach frankfurt
der russische gaskonzern gazprom trennt
sich von seiner deutschen tochter
gazprom germania
geschäftsfelder des unternehmens sind
der handel der transport und die
speicherung von erdgas welche folgen das
für den gaslieferungen nach deutschland
haben wird ist noch unklar hinzu kommen
unsicherheiten wegen des rubel dekrets
dass der russische präsident gestern
erlassen hat laut bundesnetzagentur war
die gasversorgung in deutschland heute
allerdings stabil laut experten wären
mögliche konsequenzen ohnehin erstmal zu
merken weil die gasrechnungen
rückwirkend bezahlt werden
der erste in deutschland entwickelte und
gebaute hyper spektral satellit ist am
abend von cape canaveral aus ins all
gestartet eine trägerrakete des us
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex bringt den
erdbeobachtungssatelliten ten macht in
seine umlaufbahn in 650 kilometern höhe
soll er mindestens fünf jahre lang neue
erkenntnisse über den zustand von seen
wäldern oder anbauflächen liefern
nach schneechaos und norddeutschland
gestern hat es heute auch in der mitte
und im süden deutschlands geschneit
teilweise kam es zu ausfällen im
bahnverkehr und unfällen auf den straßen
am sonntag sollen die schneefälle
abklingen bis dahin zeigt sich der april
aber erstmal vielerorts im weißen gewand
ja kaum zu fassen es ist tatsächlich der
erste april heute das war die welt an
diesem freitag danke dass sie dabei und
wir empfehlen ihnen jetzt noch unser
heute-journal update hingegen 0 uhr 15
mit christoph erwärmen vom gesamten team
ihnen einen angenehmen abend sie sind
[Musik]
guten abend die schneetiefs katharina
und lotte ziehen morgen weiter nach
osten und machen ein bisschen platz für
hoch quincy aber es kommt nach wie vor
sehr kalte luft heran und so hat es ja
heute kräftig geschneit im flachland
liegen zum teil zwischen 2 und 12 cm
schnee und hier in süddeutschland ist
der regen noch gar nicht in schnee
übergegangen das wird sich jetzt aber in
der nacht ändern und auch morgen über
tag schneidet es dort kräftig weiter
erst dienstagabend wird sich der schnee
dann vollständig in die mittelgebirge
und an den alpen rand zurückgezogen
haben heute nacht aber machen sie sich
bitte auf fünf bis 15 zentimeter
neuschnee gefasst auf glätte auf straßen
und auf gehwegen im osten und im
nordosten ist es dagegen trocken bei
eisigem wind aus nordwestlichen
richtungen die temperaturen sinken auf
plus 2 bis minus fünf grad und in der
südhälfte bleibt es morgen kalt bei
werten um den gefrierpunkt bilder wird
es ja norddeutschland mit fünf bis acht
grad denn dort zeigt sich häufiger die
sonne anders im saarland in rheinland
pfalz in baden-württemberg und bayern da
schneit es noch und diese schneefälle
ziehen sich im laufe des tages an den
alpenrand zurück und am sonntag wird es
freundlich und frisch bei
höchsttemperaturen von zwei bis zehn
grad von nord westen kommt regen heran
und er breitet sich in der neuen woche
dann weiter aus es wird mild am mittwoch
liegen die temperaturen bei 7 bis 12
grad guten abend